Silver State Schools Credit Union the
sponsors of this next segment is back to
talk about how they're helping make back
to school a Happy Time here's Mercedes
with more
we are so happy to Welcome Matt Scott
arkles from Silver State Schools Credit
Union to the show Scott for decades
Silver State Schools Credit Union you do
something really cool you encourage
students with these budding artists with
the Happy Times Calendar contest how
does that work yeah Mercedes thanks for
having us back and and I really want to
tell you this is really one of my
favorite times of year and uh and really
I love this program because what it
represents is uh our area students and
also anyone in the grades K through 12
being able to participate in so students
can submit artwork depicting what makes
them happy and the winning submissions
are then showcased in our annual Happy
Times Calendar for members and our
community to see and enjoy so one winner
from each grade level we will receive a
hundred dollar cash prize in their
original artwork will then be framed
commemorate their achievement and
oftentimes what we do to Mercedes Jesus
to post these things in our Branch
offices and so it's it almost uh acts as
a almost a member a commemorative for
them and so it's really unique for them
um well the submission deadline for the
2023 Happy Times Calendar is uh
September 30th so that'll be here before
we know it and details are available on
our website at
silverstatecu.com happy times it's so
incredible how talented these students
are and what you do to give them this
platform is so great and speaking of
students Silver State Schools Credit
Union they just held their annual back
to school supply drive again this year
how did that go and thanks for asking
Mercedes our annual back to school
supply Drive was a great success again
this year it supports our local
community and directly benefits our
Focus goals so our Focus schools are Rex
Bell Elementary and Stanford Elementary
from CCSD in addition we deliver back to
school supplies for the girl empowerment
Middle School also known as gems and
that's an all schools non-profit Public
Charter Middle School for grades six
through eight and uh thanks to the
combined donations from our members and
the community the people over Providence
Foundation was able to make these much
needed donations to our local students
and so a big thank you goes out to
everybody's donated
well thank you goes out to you because
you guys are always doing stuff in the
community what other community
initiatives do you have in the works
right now so we're planning actually a
food drive a floating drive and even a
toy drive by the end of the year and so
I'll tell you more as we get closer to
those events and we are excited to hear
about them and help in any way possible
Silver State Schools Credit Union is
fantastic I'm a member my daughters are
members and we're proud to say that we
belong to such a great organization
thank you so much Scott we appreciate
you too Mercedes thank you
thank you again to Silver State schools
Credit Union for sponsoring this segment
for more information just call
702-733-8820 or visit
silverstatecu.com Las Vegas now we'll be
right back